with high gas prices this year many
Rideshare drivers were just struggling
to make ends meet but now with the
holidays here and gas prices lower how
are those drivers doing Madison
Kimbrough spoke to those working tonight
she is live near Desert Inn and the 15
in Madison a busy day for them with
probably a lot of pickups at the airport
yeah very busy as Rideshare drivers are
looking forward to the week ahead as
they say the drop in gas prices means
they are back in business
I just filled up
10 minutes ago 35 dollars
two months ago that was 55 dollars
you know 20 bucks that's that's
positivity Avid Rideshare driver Joe
Vaughn getting ready to book his next
ride here at the Rideshare lot Vaughn
who felt the effects of high gas prices
this summer says things are looking up
now the gas prices have dropped the week
before New Year's Day is usually really
pretty good we're expecting a you know
new new people coming to town There's a
much more events than there were last
year at this time people are you know
shaking off the cobwebs from you know
being cooped up for two or three years
unlike Vaughn many drivers had to put
their Rideshare operations in Park after
sky-high gas prices caused them to lose
profit many stating that it just wasn't
worth it anymore to drive and burn that
fuel Rideshare driver Tim skeeth puts
premium in his vehicle and says well
there is a little bit of a lull during
the holidays drivers are making money
once again every December we have to
prepare for a two-week Gap where things
are just going to slow down kids are
getting out of school Christmas is
coming up up so right about that time
the gas prices dropped about a dollar
down but right now since things are
picking up that's really going to help
us out quite a bit
Rideshare companies like Lyft partnering
with the Nevada Coalition for Zero
fatalities offering discounted rides now
you'll get five dollars off when using
the Lyft app that's good through
tomorrow morning and that code should be
up on your screen reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now